ce soir on parte frontière
kenyane
pour emmener tous ces affaires de
nourriture de médicaments
à des gens qui avaient besoin
[Musique]
vitaly mikic ou qu'est né en ukraine
après neuf ans dans la légion étrangère
en france il ouvre un garage à lherm
nous en vendée il y a quelques jours il
reçoit un appel d'un ami rentrer dans la
défense territoriale ukraine - demandez
est-ce que j'ai pas j'ai pas mon casque
gilet pare balles ou des des affaires
militaires pour l'envoyer parce que
l'armée ou gagnant d'accord ils sont
bien équipés mais défensifs étaient
allés ils sont juste perçu une arme
c'est tout c'est la guerre
le vêtement civile j'ai commencé à
chercher des affaires militaires vais
appeler mes copains et mes amis de mon
mécanicien j'ai demandé pour qu'il
fournisse ces affaires qui n'a pas
besoin et bouche à oreille petit à petit
sa répartie un petit peu le maire des
terminaux qui sont approchés et on avait
discuté avec lui il n'en proposait
conférence a peut-être un peu plus on
mettra un article dans le journal trois
jours en arrière je vais je vais juste
ma casque à la main et puis il peut y
manger le combat et c'est tout ce que je
voulais ramener envoyés en ukraine quand
je faisais pas quels moyens et
aujourd'hui on a déjà eu sa mi remorque
plan d affaires des médicaments des
affaires chaudes sacs de couchage des
plans différents chose que tous les gens
sont nous emmener il fut très touché
parce que je vois il ya des gens qui
viennent il pleure je sais pas je n'y
arrive pas pleure parce que je suis un
plus quand est ce que je ferais dernière
fois il y en a des gens qui des français
qui vit en france qui viendront ici aux
gages qui m'emmène de quelque chose d
affaires ou deux nourriture pour que je
ramène là bas et il pleurait mais si
j'ai beaucoup de gens qui m'ont proposé
des
des chambres des choses ont entièrement
gratuite nourriture tous dit s'il ya
quelqu'un qui a besoin donc j'ai du
chanvre ou trois chambres où je sais pas
une maison c'est un an après des gens il
y 15 c'est aussi europe même si
formalité c'est pas il pas dans l'union
européenne mais c'est des peuples
européens donc les gens ne se
fait pas il se met à sa place peut-être
imagine que c'est dommage ça peut ça
peut arriver ici quelques jours personne
ne pensait que ça peut ça peut venir en
ukraine mais
est ce qu on est sûr que demain ça sera
pas la même chose ici
et après
beaucoup de médicaments ou pas
parce que j'ai pas mal dans le camion
des jets d affaires mais d'etarras aussi
donc je vais avancer tout à l'heure
là-bas avec camion et puis on va charger
une verra ce que la musique
parce que j'ai aussi de votre
22 heures de conduite sans arrêt pour
aller sans appel donc 40 14 conduite
aller retour sans arrêt et je parte avec
un ami ou craignant avec lui en faire un
phare à 2
des allers retours comme ça vraiment il
ya une centre centre
centre labaki et qui prend de tous les
avions militaires et on voit après dans
le camp si je me trompe pas d'un livre
c'est une grande ville à l'ouest des
pays et après ça ça dispatch là où il
faut je sais pas combien de camions il
faudra envoyer mais il y en a des gens
qui étaient dans qui donc beaucoup
d'argent
quand merci pour ça ça va nous aider
merci beaucoup
merci d'avoir 10 mt
oui
bien sûr merci bonne journée ça me
touche profondément ce qui se passe je
mets le considérait comme des ennemis
puis oui on a des familles en russie
c'était c'était 2
deux peuples
frères et soeurs on peut dire c'était la
même famille à l'époque l'une à manger
pourra partir en ukraine se battre aussi
avec des soldats mais et en plus j'ai
quelques connaissances mais mais bon
c'est aussi un jeu
j'étais à la guerre je sais qu est ce
que c'est
c'est pas que j'ai pas envie de
ressentir mais je sais que c'est très
dangereux et puis moi ma famille est là
et ici je suis pas là qu'est ce qu'est
ce qu'ils vont faire
donc
si je suis au niveau du crâne oui je
répartis je suis à sa place et je
pourrais en faire beaucoup plus de
choses
de bonnes choses d ici être plus
efficace ici que là-bas